people think it started with us well it
didn't know the Jackman's and Reynolds
have been mortal enemies for as long as
there have been Jackman's and Reynolds
is this is a generations it's been a
point of family honor to oppose each
other Wow the feud goes all the way back
to the wild wild west now we really only
got the inside scoop to the decades-long
war when you revealed this week that he
used to rib Ryan back in 2008 when they
met on a set of Wolverine now back then
Ryan was still married to Hughes friend
Scarlett Johansson Hugh told The Daily
Beast quote I was like hey ya better be
on your best behavior here pal because
I'm watching and we started ribbing each
other that way and then it all escalated
with the Deadpool thing and him calling
me out and trying to manipulate me
through social media to do what he
wanted good I might Hugh Jackman here
just reminding you to get your votes in
for people sexiest men alive kavas
coming up it's hilarious moments like
that that have kept us entertained for
years but unbelievably the tube uploaded
a video announcing a truce to their feud
but there's a catch 24 hours in fact
there's only one thing that we do agree
on freely to stop
well for one day and one day only we've
agreed to agree to not disagree and only
a pandemic could could make that happen
we've agreed to join the all-in
challenge you'd agree to be all in
challenge but they're not only pausing
their bitter feud they're joining other
celebrities like Leonardo DiCaprio
Robert De Niro and Justin Bieber by
giving away items or experiences for
charity so while Hugh and Ryan are
normally in the business of promoting
their gin and coffee companies they've
decided why not try something a little
sweeter for their experience will stop
our feud for one day and help sell a
different type of drinking lemonade at
your child's lemonade standards right
all to help fight food insecurity
because no one deserves to go hungry
just go to this go to this website it's
a you or nobody calls it equip sorry
sorry we're doing this here we go guys
we're doing this
[Music]